Speaker 1: So we had a mass shooting
yesterday, you might say, David,
that's not rare in the United States, mass
shootings are very common and you would be
completely correct. So I guess what I mean is we
had a mass shooting yesterday in the United States
that rose to a level of getting some national
attention on the four five, six seven p.m.
news when we were doing a live stream yesterday,
covering a number of different things.
News of this mass shooting at a shopping mall in
Boise, Idaho, started to sort of percolate through
national media and we now have more details
about it. But as I always do any time we talk
about a specific mass shooting, I take it
as an opportunity to remind you and myself
that mass shootings in the United States are very
common and shootings in general. Ones that don't
count as mass shootings but just shootings in
general are incredibly common. And in fact,
yesterday there were a number of mass shootings
and 57 known shootings that got at least
some media coverage, 57 yesterday. And
most of us, if we heard about any of them,
heard only about the one shooting in Boise,
Idaho. So let's start with what happened in Idaho.
Police say two dead and four injured in this Idaho
mall shooting. A suspect is in custody after two
people were killed and four injured, including a
police officer in a shooting at a shopping mall
on Monday. Authorities said officers exchanged
gunfire with the suspect. Police on Monday evening
said in a news release that the suspect
was in critical condition at a hospital.
The officer who was hurt was treated and released.
As of this morning, we don't know more about the
victims officer or suspect, although I suspect
maybe by the time today's show is published,
more will be known. The mall was secured by
Monday evening. It would remain closed for now.
Boise Police Chief Ryan Lee said the shooting was
reported around 150 p.m. Monday. That's, you know,
I don't remember if Idaho is on a mountain or
Pacific time, but that would make it 350 or 450
on the East Coast, including a report that
one person was shot and down. At that time.
When officers arrived, they spotted someone
matching the description of the suspect.
There was an exchange of gunfire last night. The
police chief said We can't really comment more.
I don't know that there's much more to say
about this particular shooting. So where does
that get as well? Reminder, the ones that make
national news are the tiniest tiny minority. So
for example, yesterday you can go to gun violence
archive.org and you will see that there were 57
different shootings with specific reporting,
meaning we have incident information and we
have at least a news source. And you could just go
through and look, oh, in Elgin or Elgin, Illinois,
there was a shooting with
one killed and two injured
in Duvall, Texas. There were two people
injured and you just go through and its
pages and pages. Three people injured in
Charlotte, North Carolina, at a shooting,
one killed, one injured in Kansas City, Kansas.
It's all over the country and its pages and pages
and 57 different shootings yesterday with
specific reporting. You can pick any of these,
I don't know Memphis, Tennessee and look at a
source. Parents rally in Memphis after shooting
sends three teams to the hospital. Every single
one of these is a story with people and families
and friends and communities affected every single
one. There were 57 yesterday. You go back. I mean,
just let's pick another one. Tulsa, Oklahoma,
where one person was killed. Let's look at that.
Deadly shooting investigation at South Tulsa
apartment complex. This one was at an apartment
complex. Every single one of these is a story
and then you say, Well, David, sir, those are
not all mass shootings and you would be right,
but then you can actually go and you can look
at the mass shootings as well. And yesterday there
were three. The Boise, Idaho Mass shooting is one
where two people were killed and six injured. In
Memphis, Tennessee, there was a mass shooting with
four people injured. And then in Winston-Salem,
North Carolina, Winston, I hope I pronounce that
right. Winston-Salem, North Carolina One person
killed and three people injured every single day.
You can find dozens and then usually
three to a handful of mass shootings.
And we have so many people, you know, there's
just no way to prevent it. It's it's crazy. We
we really can't do anything. And yet this is
the country at our level of development and
our level of wealth. OK, I know people will say,
David, look at Liberia. OK. I don't know, is it
really a comparison to the United States in
many, many different ways? But there's people
who say it's just we just can't figure out what
to do. There's really no way to prevent this. And
yet it's really only happening here. The unique
combination of widespread availability of guns,
very lax gun safety regulations. And this is the X
Factor. Remember this fetishizing of gun culture,
seeing guns as a way to solve interpersonal
problems and lack of access to or stigmatization
of mental health care? It's all of these
different things. It's sort of like a
horrible combination in the United States
of a cultural aspect. Some economic aspects
and public health aspects all coming
together really, really horrifying.
But that's the latest one shooting that made the
news. There were three mass shootings yesterday
and 57 shootings that we know of,
based on at least some reporting.